bonsoir
alors carmen been la dig comme vous
dites vous êtes la belle-soeur donc
d'oussama ben laden
pourquoi avoir pris been la dinepa ben
laden c'est comme ça que le compère de
maisons pour les cris des as et certains
frères l'ont changé à sa maman vous êtes
bien carmen ben laden oui comment
réagissent les gens à votre votre nom
hier en venant à paris le deuxième n'a
raté à regarder sur son compte twitter
allez est allé derrière train de
téléphoner et pour finir une malle s est
passé le grand regret que je le
passeport suisse ce qui facilite quand
même d'avoir le passeport 6 avec le nom
de ben laden ce n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose que d'avoir un passeport
saoudien avec
vous j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis après le
11 septembre
je crois que c'était je pense que ce
n'est pas vraiment d des amis alors vous
apparteniez à une famille des plus
prestigieuses d'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui ben laden vous êtes un petit
peu devenu une sorte de deux parias non
oui aussi oui entre autres du difficile
je crois qu'elle pour mes fils est très
très difficile c'est très difficile
parce que c'est un nous réalisons que
c'est un nom auquel on peut pas
s'échapper c'est à dire et changer le
nom ne change rien j'oserais rien on
dira toujours même j'ai vraiment
conscience que même si demain c'est des
jeunes filles si elles se marient et
prennent le nom de leur mari on dira
toujours est uc72 vettel mais l'aîné
dans votre fille ou afin était accusé
d'avoir été prévenu du 11 septembre et
d'avoir retardé son retour à new york où
elle vivait alors que votre fille en
fête devait rentrer le 15 à new york
elle n'a pas retardé son départ à cause
du 11 septembre l'a pas été prévenus à
l'avancé
ni à genève pour l'été et
elle était rentrée pour les vacances
ouais
alors quand vous apprenez l'attentât du
world trade center vous êtes dans votre
voiture vous allez de lausanne à genève
avec votre fille wafa justement un ami
vous appelle de new york après l'impact
dans la première tour du world trade
center et avant l'impact du deuxième
avion
tout de suite vous pensez que c'est nous
sommes abdelhaleem votre lot frère
je me souviens très bien la première
quand il m'a dit attends il ya un autre
avion et mon dieu il rentre dans un dans
la second tour
et moi ma première réaction c'était
mon dieu leur nom va être partout dans
les jambes j'ai pas pensé aux femmes
âgées pas penser j'ai dit ma lieu leur
nom va être partout dans les geôles 1
alors j'ai été vraiment inquiète alors
carmen ben laden vous publié chez michel
lafon le voile déchirée ou vous racontez
votre histoire alors votre mariage avec
l'un des frères donc d'oussama ben laden
les neuf ans que vous avez passé en
arabie saoudite dans le clan ben laden
vos rencontres avec votre beau-frère
oussama est votre combat pour fuir tout
ça avec vos trois filles alors on va
prendre les choses par le par le
commencement votre mère donc est issu de
l'aristocratie iranienne elle avait mis
sa famille devant le fait accompli en
fait en épousant secrètement à paris
monsieur dufour citoyens suisses
rencontré à lausanne pendant ses études
il était quoi votre père homme
d'affaires oui
alors vos parents se sont séparés quand
vous étiez très jeunes avaient eu plus
aucun contact avec votre père votre
maire a pris soin de rendre ça tout à
fait étanche quoi
alors votre maire elle est née musulmane
n'était pas très pratique quand un nom
mais le faisais pas de ramadan elle le
priait pas très souvent
je suis arrivé en arabie saoudite je
sais toujours pas prier je ne savais pas
prier alors là au printemps 1973
vous êtes agenaise donc que vous vivez à
l'époque avec votre mère est
malheureusement plus votre père il ya
beaucoup de touristes saoudiens qui
viennent à un genève pour l'été vous
devez partir en vacances en iran dans la
famille de votre mère et votre mère sous
loue un étage de sa maison donc quand
vous n'êtes pas là aux frères d'oussama
ben laden qui s'appelle et cela mène la
laine donc et puis vous tombe follement
amoureuse de lui voilà vous partez
suivre ensemble vos études aux usa et
aux usa vous découvrez l'importance de
la famille ben laden c'est dire que en
arrivant là bas il ya des gens
l'université qui vous ont dit mais c'est
des gens extrêmement puissant
extrêmement important oui j'ai rencontré
un étudiant saoudien qui était dans ma
classe parler qui est qui est bien mais
avec les semelles l'ademe le cheikh
hamad était quelqu'un de qui était très
respecté en arabie saoudite
et qu'il avait beaucoup aidé et c'est là
où j'ai réalisé 1 vous savez à l'époque
personne ne parlait de
y avait pas encore eu le choc pétrolier
dans une arabie saoudite qui n'était pas
l'arabie saoudite actuelle et il était
plutôt prestigieux aux yeux des
saoudiens alors le mariage a lieu en
arabie saoudite vous auriez préféré
genève mais vous n'avez pas vous avez
pas gain de cause et là en arrivant vous
découvrez la bahia c'est à dire qu'on
vous habille de la balle ya en vous vous
en rendez pas compte mais vous regardez
votre soeur salomé et vous découvrez
qu'en fait on va même pas ses yeux
quoique c'est complètement envoyez rien
ct ct et j'avais pris le voile à la
manière mais je l'avais je l'avais fait
à genève et c'était vraiment très épais
très opaque et
oui c'est
le voir c'était au début pour moi ça
fait quelque chose d'amusant c'était
quelque chose vous savez comme moi je
porte le voile ce qui ce qui put quand
je suis arrivé ce que je dis est ce
qu'on m'avait dit qu'il n'y avait rien
pas de théâtre pas de deux
deux librairies pas de cinéma pas de
restaurant et de l'entente vous dis dans
mon cas il n'ya pas mais vous l'imaginez
pas c'est quand vous êtes là ce que vous
imaginez qu est-ce que c'est vraiment
non il n'y a vraiment rien rien là vous
découvrez donc la vie des femmes en
arabie saoudite évidemment confinées à
la maison
ne devant pas être vu par des hommes
extérieurs à la famille et même quand
vous allez dans le jardin chez vous les
employés s'en vont pour pas vous voir
toi ma belle mère avait un chauffeur
parce que bien sûr les femmes ne
conduisait pas un habit saoudite qui
l'amenait d'une maison à l'autre et le
chauffeur n'avait jamais vu le visage de
ma belle mère alors que vous en faites
après quelques temps le chauffeur voit
votre visage
bien plus tard tout à fait voilà donc
une drôle de vie avec les journaux qui
arrive caviardé avec des traits noirs à
cause de son surpoids la première fois
que j'étais
alors là bas tout est pêché à la
promenade c'est un péché la musique
c'est un péché la danse c'est un péché
l'art heureusement votre mari vous
traite pas comme ses frères traitent
leurs femmes
effectivement vous vous participez à
l'époque à un semblant de modernisation
en arabie saoudite on allait encore là
dans les supermarchés à voile et tout et
je me suis toujours demandée par exemple
comment parce que je sortais du
supermarché mon chauffeur savez ils
venaient exactement se mettre à côté de
moi et j'étais sous la voie à l'échelon
national et oui c'était vraiment
surprenant c'est surprenant non ça
c'était avant la chute du chah d'iran et
l'arrivée de commenee donc à téhéran
après il ya eu un véritable retour en
arrière si on vous dit que les femmes
ont été obligées de porter non seulement
des abayas mais des bas noirs sous les
abayas pourquoi qu'on voit un petit bout
de leur cher ce qui était obligatoire
c'est-à-dire en d'ordre c'était l'émeute
à voir la police religieuse
et où il avait été peut-être une année
plutôt un peu plus laxistes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne faisaient pas sortir des
magasins au moment des prières et j'ai
senti un certain laxisme à ce moment là
de nouveau on nous faisait ressortir des
magasins les magasins étaient fermés on
devait remplir on va lire les magasins
devaient être fermés les gens ville et
encore maintenant en arabie saoudite à
l'heure de la prière les magasins sauf
tarn les gens sortent et en général vous
savez où vous attendez dans les voitures
en tout cas moi j'ai j'attendais dans la
voiture avec mon chauffeur jusqu'à un
quart d'heure jusqu'à que la prière
c'est terminé je retournais dans le
magasin alors à ce moment là vous
découvrez que vos filles subissent des
influences néfastes présent vous
découvrez que sur un cahier on leur a
fait écrire je hais les juifs j'aime la
palestine alors vous vous êtes choqués
évidemment mars à l'école à l'école
c'est très bien dit d'aller à l'école et
je leur ai demandé si messi prenait des
cours de géographie parce qu'en faire et
7 ans il m'a dit nous ne nous en donne
les cours déjà fier dix ans alors j'ai
dit si j'appelle ma fille et je lui
demande de montrer sur la carte la
palestine est ce qu'elle sera aussi le
mot dit non nous allongeons je vous dis
à 11 ans dont vous lui apprenez à lire
quelque chose qu'elle n'arrivait même
pas à placer sur la carte que vous allez
voir la directrice de l'école qui vous
dit vous n'y comprenez rien toutefois
sans vous êtes une étrangère et cette
phrase terrible elle vous dit est ce que
votre mari est au courant de votre
démarche c'est à dire que ça donne avec
la rue mont avec moi parce que j'ai je
me suis et comment dire
j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que je ne
voulais pas que mes filles haïssent
quelqu'un sur la base de leur religion
de là et je lui ai même dit si un jour
je peut à la rigueur à accepter que ma
fille ait quelqu'un mais je voudrais
qu'elle ait au moins une bonne raison et
jeu est là elle me dit à court
d'arguments elle se retourne vers moi
elle me regarde comme ça elle dit est ce
que vous êtes marié courant ici et
j'étais furieuse je lui ai dit écoutez
mon mari va vous téléphoner je suis
rentré à la maison et j'ai dit à sa
femme si tu appelles pas
cette personne que je ne resterai pas
ici et il a téléphoné à aubigny sépare
partir de là bas en 85 vous installer en
suisse donc votre marié vous le sentez
un petit peu de s'éloigner de s'éloigner
de vous à ce moment là et vous découvrez
qu'il vous trompe un soir où balader
dans jeunet avec votre voiture et vous
voyez sortir avec ça avec sa secrétaire
de son bureau
je crois que ça peut arriver ça mais
c'est sa réaction plus tard c'est à dire
que sa réaction m'a fait penser beaucoup
plus à une réaction
d'un homme saoudien qui s'était très
normal
alors vous vous êtes plus jamais
retournés en arabie saoudite depuis
carmen je pouvais pas parce que comme
votre mari vous a accusé d'adultère la
bâtisse c'est passible de la peine de
mort je sais qu'en arabie saudite et ça
je le sais et il n'a pas besoin de moi
pour divorcer ah oui
alors j'assume qu'il m'a apprise et
d'adultère et de quoi aujourd'hui j'ai
une pension alimentaire qui était et je
suis ce qu'on appelle en suisse on
mesure provisoire c'est à dire que le
juge
me donne
pour subvenir à mes besoins pas beaucoup
non non par rapport à ceux qui gagnent
sans pilote s'est pas beaucoup non
exactement
alors votre mari a beaucoup d'argent il
a quand même énormément de sociétés
offshore vous dites 75 et c'est
quelqu'un qui est quand même lié au
commerce international aux flux
financiers internationaux d'une façon un
petit peu opaque il a d'ailleurs tenté
de faire interdire en suisse un livre
s'appelle la vérité interdite de dasquié
brizard qu'on a reçu ici l'année
dernière et puis le juge vendre une baie
café perquisitionné sa villa cannoise
avec la bergerie sur une enquête donc de
blanchiment blanchiment d'argent est ce
que vous pensez qu'à travers ces
circuits financiers un petit peu opaque
donc la famille ben laden et votre mari
entre autres continuent à soutenir
financièrement oussama ben laden je
pense qu'il ya
énormément de gens en arabie saoudite
qui soutient tous les causes islamistes
je ne pense pas vous savez je ne suis
pas en train de dire que si
si oussama ou quelqu'un comme ça m'a
bien dire j'ai besoin d'argent pour
faire sauter une ambassade on va lui
donner de l'argent mais s'il vient mais
ils disent vous savez je vais faire
trois ou quatre modèles sa
mosquée
séoul a valu le déni on ne va pas
hésiter à lui le départ garder ce qui
fait du pognon je vous dis dans votre
bouquin qu'il est très très proche le
d'abdallah qui est le prince héritier
d'arabie ça c'est une chose que j'aime
que mon mari me l'a dit je me souviens
très bien mais je ne dis pas que toute
la famille royale le soutien mais je
pense que comme
il y à des membres de la famille royale
qui qui qui sont tout à fait d'accord
avec eux avec oussama du reste vous
savez pour beaucoup d'arabes j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler ils disent qu'ils
étaient la preuve qu sa main a été
impliqué dans ces attentats n'existe pas
et quand il parle de cette base là
église bondée
et les occidentaux la cus centre
et la revendiquer quand même il dit ce
qui d'après j'ai eu une conversation
justement avec quelqu'un qui m'a dit en
eau non mais vous c'est avec la
technologie moderne on peut on peut
faire dire n'importe quoi sur
cet argent il est transmis comment vous
pensez si c'est pas par des banques sans
liquide non bien sûr vous savez moi à
coacher arabie saoudite ou dans les pays
du moyen-orient tout se passe les gens
utilisent beaucoup de cash
donc ya pas de traces mais à l'époque je
n'ai jamais eu des carnets de chèques en
arabie saudite je n'ai jamais eu de
zinda kaboré de l'argent oui j'avais
est ce que vous croyez que cela ben
laden est toujours en vie je suis
persuadé qu'il est en vie parce que je
pense que si quelque chose était arrivée
à ossama la famille le ferai savoir oui
pour faire baisser la pression qu'ils
auront ce qu'ils ont sur eux pour être
un peu plus tranquille
alors maintenant la question à 25
millions de dollars
ça va si j'avais savait et on peut se
partager le pognon
il est où
on arrondit qu'ils
ont dit qu'ils étaient au pakistan ou en
afghanistan dans les zones tribales à la
frontière entre pakistan et en
afghanistan
aucune idée sinon 25 millions de dollars
voilà vous raconter tout ça donc dans un
bouquin qui s'appelle le voile déchirée
vous rencontrez évidemment aussi vous
vos rencontres avec oussama ben laden
alors c'est extraordinaire un jour vous
êtes à tayeb je crois il fait super
chaud
et puis moi ici d'accord maïs il voulait
qu'on baisse la clim s'il vous plaît si
on peut baisser un petit peu la clim
parce que c'est vrai que ce n'est pas le
climat de l'arabie saoudite ce soir donc
un jour cet internet il fait très chaud
on vous voyez là femmes d'oussama ben
laden qui nourrit leurs enfants à la
petite cuillère avec de l'eau avec de
l'eau alors vous dites pourquoi pas mais
bon je lui ai offert bon du moment elle
a refusé je ne comprenais pas et je me
rappelle je dis à ma belle mère mais cet
enfant risque est déshydratée pourquoi
il lui donne pas le des pros et au début
j'ai naïvement je croyais que je lui dis
mais mon biberon est à réaliser et
et l ai dit nono samardzic et nous
sommes à voulait pas quoique l'enfant et
le bouchon dans la bouche dans la pièce
oui et j'ai fait appeler yeslam en
disant écoute va parler avec ton frère
parce que cet enfant va ce désastre est
déshydratée humains et les revenus en me
disant non ils refusent catégoriquement
mais pourquoi diable le caoutchouc sais
pas si je peux pas être le cas où tu
peux pas être interdit par le coran
puisque c'est pas du tournoi aux mails
cas où tu laisses moi je ne sais pas ça
ne saute et je ne comprenais pas non
plus j'ai c'était une honte à ma refuse
que son bien son fils prendre le biberon
alors en descendant cet incident m'a
marqué parce que c'était aux chemins
c'est cet incident on m'a marqué parce
que pour la première fois j'ai réalisé
le poids de la parole d'un homme même
s'il n'était pas dans la pièce
et que toutes ces femmes et moi on était
impuissante à faire quoi que ce soit et
et tout le long du retour dans la
voiture
je
j'ai pensé mon dieu c'est quelque chose
à l'époque tout allait bien entre mon
mari et moi et moi j'avais quand même
beaucoup de facilité c'est à dire que
mon mari des enfants étaient plus petits
accepté ma manière d'éduquer les enfants
et j'ai eu une angoisse profonde en me
disant mais si quelque chose arrivait
agasson et inde un de ses frères devenez
un sur le tuteur les enfants
et là c'était vraiment peur
c'est la première qu'on me dit en
anglais le premier quatre corps oui le
sait les alarmes l'alarmé qui ne m'a
plus jamais quitté et je crois que ça à
partir de ce moment là où j'ai commencé
à observer pour les petits détails de
l'arabie saudite les tout ce qui
pourrait
tout ce qui se passait pour essayer
d'analyser de comprendre et eux et c'est
une autre fois aussi où vous croisez
oussama ben laden vous êtes chez vous
dans le jardin on sonne à la porte vous
l'ouvrez sans réfléchir il vous voit et
qu'est ce qui se passe
et il me regarde et je ils me regardent
et se tourne c'était quelques secondes
vous fait signe de partir et il me fait
comme ça et je n'ai pas réalisé
je les ai suivis j'ai dit nono et cela
mais là et son neveu qui était avec lui
m'a dit ça ou ça m'a aidé et j'ai
réalisé ces nous sommes alors je suis
parti c'est à dire qu'oussama il a
toujours été comme ça quoi depuis son
plus jeune âge il était extrêmement
pieux est alors proposée pour ses frères
pour sa famille il est une sorte de
héros j'imagine parce que il est parti
se battre en afghanistan et tout ça en
plus d'avoir de l'argent il a une espèce
de sacralité un petit peu comme ramed
chèque le père non avant de partir en
afghanistan sa main était un frère comme
les autres et après quand il est parti
en afghanistan pour se battre contre les
soviétiques et il est devenu un héros
pour seulement la famille ben laden pour
dumont pour tout le monde tout le monde
pourquoi vous avez écrit ce bouquin
côté ce bouquin c'est
une explique l'explication du maire à
ses filles parce que je sais que
mes filles ont eu un prix émotionnel à
payer pour
parce qu'elle s'appelle ben laden et
pour les décisions que j'ai prises pour
elle c'est à dire que je sais que si
j'avais accepté de suivent les règles
saoudienne et de les élever un peu plus
dans l'est la culture saoudienne
peut-être qu'elle n'aurait pas été
rejetés par leur famille et je crois que
ça a été très douloureux pour mes filles
d'être rejeté par là par la famille
elles ont lu le bouquin vos filles oui
elles disent quoi
elles m'ont dit qu'elles mêmes ont elles
font a dit c'est bien nous venons de
mahdia c'est fantastique les 28 décès
très bien quand vous dites j'ai vécu au
sein du clan ben laden je connais la
société saoudienne et j'ai peur pour
l'avenir de l'humanité c'est-à-dire que
vous pensez que
finalement la culture occidentale ne
peut rien faire finalement face à ces
fondamentalistes prêt à tout vous savez
j'appelle les fondamentalistes une armée
de l'ombre
ils sont là on ne sait pas si vous
regardez les tragédies de durand
septembre
3900 détruit comme ça avec et avec
quelles armes un avion comme que vous
prenez que je prends tout le monde prend
et 19 personnes après une année après
avoir passé une année dans une société
qui n'a pas pu les influencer en quoi
trésor ont mis en exécution
ils ont besoin de prendre notre
technologie pour le retourner contre
nous et ça c'est sa maîtresse vous
croyez en l'islam modéré
j'aimerais croire en islam modéré ou ce
qui me fait peur aussi si vous savez
quand je suis allé en au début des
années soixante quatorze en arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite était le seul
pays qui étaient sous la halle sur la
charia
et ce quand je regarde tout ce qui s'est
passé
malgré tout toute cette évolution ya eu
dans le monde de plus en plus de pays
demandent et ça ça mettrait et quand
vous voyez à leur jeu oui je crois qu'il
ya parce qu'autrement ça serait terrible
c'est un islam modéré sur ou pensez quoi
de la querelle du voile à l'école en
france
écoutez je
je je trouve que je ne peux pas accepter
qu'en consommant koné a accepté le voile
ici parce que vous savez ça l'utiliser
en arabie saoudite par exemple ils ont
une moitié de la population qui est qui
et étrangères ils ont beaucoup de
philippins deux qui sont de religion
catholique il n'y a pas une seule église
pour d'accord et quand je vois ces
excuses moi ces femmes qui descendent
dans la rue et qui revendique 2 le port
du voile dans une société laïque et qui
veulent que nous on oublie notre culture
à nous
et au sens où vous et essai ces femmes
quand il ya encore pas si longtemps il
ya trois ans le régime taliban
étaient en train de prix mais leur chef
pourquoi elles sont pas descendus et
avoir les mêmes revendications pour un
pour un régime qui opprimait normal oui
vous vous pensez quoi vous pensez que
les clés français disons les européens
et occidentaux peu importe vous pensez
qu'ils sont trop finalement faible face
à ça vous pensez que ici le côté
république chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça
donne trop de deux possibilités je pense
que je pense qu'on doit être vigilant
qu'il n'utilise pas notre indulgence
pour pour imposer leur intolérance voilà
carmen ben laden donc le voile déchirée
c'est chez michel lafon merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous avons choisi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu